[Music]
i have a pretty unique role here at the
university of arizona as their outreach
librarian i fulfill
the land-grant mission which is our
responsibility to serve all communities
in the state of arizona
my end goal is to increase health
literacy in the whole state
the university of arizona health
sciences library is the resource library
within the national network of libraries
of medicine for the state of arizona
it's a role that we've had for a very
long time and we're very proud of that
and we work very hard on that work
knowing that it has an impact on our
citizens here in the state so our areas
of focus really align with what's unique
and specific and special about this part
of the country
we do border health work uh in that
capacity focusing on spanish language
instruction
we also work with indigenous peoples the
various tribal communities
we also have a focus on k-12 one of the
things that really excites me about the
outreach work that we do
is that intersectionality when all three
communities come together
that's one of the specific and unusual
things about the region where we live
that we have these populations and that
there is that opportunity and that
engagement
with all three the mexican consulate
was a very strong partner that i
identified when doing work with the
spanish-speaking community
promotoras are lay workers
that have been identified by the
community as leaders
that can help them navigate the health
system we have promoted
that work in clinics we've got as our
community promoters
and that model actually started off in
mexico so it's a very interesting
concept and very kind of unique to our
region
in today's particular session they were
very interested in learning more about
social determinants of health
so we did a little bit of activity to
kind of
get that going and define it ourselves i
tied in a lot of the cultural aspect by
bringing the music
that is very popular in that particular
community
and really kind of getting them to think
about health topics and how
our ambience really affects our health
and then went ahead and introduced them
to some of the national library of
medicine resources
as a way for them to introduce those
resources to the clientele that they
work with but also
empower them to question a lot of the
things that are going on in their
environment
and to really be their own advocates
when it comes to health
where we would be without the resources
of the national library of medicine
it's critical for the constituencies
that we serve
many of the groups with which we work
are traditionally
underrepresented in the healthcare
environment underserved populations
the pacific southwest region of the
national network of libraries of
medicine
covers over six time zones
we have many different populations
and we make use of some of the academic
medical centers as kind of leverage for
our outreach program and
we can offer them some funding that
helps support the work that they do
in their regions a lot of the
communities that i've worked with are
really impressed or hadn't
heard of these resources before and
they're very appreciative to the
national library of medicine for putting
those out there
for their use